ex militaire
autant d'arrestations que de mesure
disciplinaires
bienvenue vous allez vite vous y faire
de Noël à revendiquer la vague
d'attentat à la bombe qui ont frappé New
York on va coopérer à 100% avec le FBI
et le bureau du maître
il était là pour moi ce mec est un
fantôme
ce soir
de la Libération vous qui êtes censé
faire respecter la loi vous qui avez
opprimé le peuple de ce pays pendant
trop longtemps
je pensais que vous vous évaderiez avec
les autres
j'ai besoin de votre aide arrêtez le
procureur abandonnera les poursuites
contre vous je suis flatté ne
mettez-vous un truc dans le crâne comme
l'aile ne braque pas des banques
il se donne un spectacle
donnez-moi mon arme et je me charge du
reste
contre un braqueur psychopathe que la
fête commence
[Musique]
que tu chasses à monstre
cette histoire finira quand la vie de sa
mort
[Musique]
où est passé ton esprit de Noël joyeux
Noël